dangly Wren resigned following a
meltdown of Epic Proportions when his
clock dropped below one minute nine
moves away from Gaining additional time
giving janapanishi a 4-3 lead in the
fide World Championship going into round
seven both players wanted nothing more
than to find a victory in this slugfest
of a match the game started off with the
French defense unbelievable that is huge
ding played sharp out of the opening and
into the middle game to gain a great
position nepo started to put on pressure
when he activated his pieces in the
center ding found back-to-back brilliant
moves to reverse nepo's pressure and
throw it right back at him or the only
move as you said to keep the game alive
with the advantage ding allowed his
clock to drain on a single move spending
five and a half minutes only to make a
mistake
nepo could not believe it now under one
minute there was little left for ding to
do the advantage was Miles Out Of Reach
and that's when